now did you notice the last 36 hours
while the Republican field for 2024
expanded to include candidates
little to no chance at winning the
nomination so we were wondering tonight
what is motivating them pray tell well
Chris Christie threw his hat in the ring
and it's pretty obvious he's just trying
to be the flamethrower against Trump
he's a baby
whenever you want to criticize him I
mean anyway that's the way he responds
if we had a child who conducted
themselves like that we'd send them to
their room yeah not to the White House
no dinner well Penn center today as well
and he thinks that he can Surge and well
in the categories for both populous and
maybe the establishment
president Trump also demanded
that I choose between him
and the Constitution
now voters will be faced with the same
choice
I chose the Constitution
and I always will
and then there's Doug
we need a leader who's clearly focused
on three things economy energy and
National Security and that is why today
I'm officially announcing I'm running
for the president of the United States
of America workout
joining me now is former Speaker of the
House Fox News contributor Newt Gingrich
she's also the author of March to the
majority all right Newt um let's start
with Mike Pence
um what do you think is driving his
entry into the race at this point
well I mean look Pence has been a good
Congressman the governor a vice
president uh he's young fit smart has a
nationwide base of people who admire his
traditional conservatism and I think he
sort of thinks why not I mean a lot of
these guys are focused on the idea that
somewhere down the road whether it's in
the Justice Department indictment that
we were told today is about to occur or
it's the Atlanta indictment or it's some
other thing that magically Trump will
disappear and then there will be a wide
open race and frankly in a wide open
race Mike Pence is very attractive just
as Governor DeSantis is very attractive
I don't agree with the album for all of
them I don't agree with that I don't
agree with that I mean I love I love
Mike Pence as a person and I adore him
as a person actually and I think he's
done a lot of great things for the
country
but pants for some reason Stills caught
in the old establishment GOP Wing more
of the kind of bush wing of the party I
think he played populace with Trump he's
not really a populist and again I like
him a lot I mean DeSantis yes because
he's a populist he's more of a America
First conservative but if Trump goes
away Trump's views are still going to be
dominant in the party new that's my
point so all these guys can say
everything they want about the rah-rah
Reagan days of the of the GOP but that
old Coalition is gone that Coalition
does not exist anymore
well you may be right on the other hand
maybe you're not the fact is I'm not I'm
not sure the average voter goes out
there and says themselves gee am I part
of the Reagan Coalition what the average
voter wants to know is are you going to
help fix inflation are you going to help
fix the economy are you going to control
the Border are you going to fix our
schools are you going to knock down the
weird left-wing wokism I mean they have
a series of things they want and any of
these candidates potentially could make
a case for including the governor of
North Dakota who is a self-funding
billionaire uh and an interesting guy
and again you're you're in he's a global
environment
yeah but he's a globalist I mean I I
think again he's interesting but Newt
you come on this show week after week
which we love uh and we've pointed out
on the border on trade on China on all
these issues that the establishment GOP
got so screwed up for this country
ushering and Obama and all the disasters
that he brought from the wars on out
they're still clinging to those I mean
if they could they'd do another surge in
Iraq I'm telling you so I I think that
clinging to that old vision of it not
Reagan but the old vision of you know
Wars of choice of massive immigration
amnesty that it's not going to play I I
think that blows up the the Republican
uh Coalition as it currently exists if
that's the way we go and I think we lose
if that's the way we go but
but Laura I think is Canada's stupid
enough to take the positions you just
described has no hope now all of them
can do polling all of them can look at
the information all of them go out on
the stump uh very few people are going
to run out and say hi I'm a globalist uh
but I can be able to go around and say I
really love having an open border uh but
but the to me the interesting thing is
look I have a two-lake theory of what's
going on there's a very large lake that
has all the Trump voters there's a much
smaller Lake that has the non-trump
voters all of these candidates including
DeSantis who's failed to sort of make
the cut all these candidates are in the
non-trump lake fighting for about 40
percent of the party
Trump I suspect is popping champagne
corks at Mara Largo every time there's a
new candidate I mean what he wants is 15
or 20 candidates out there making a
whole range of noise and one person that
the country identifies with and if he
gets that he could be the nominee by
March
well I think that you're right about
that I mean the bigger the field the
bigger the gift to president Trump and
he will be popping champagne Corks And
all of those people are better than any
Democrat we know that Newt I love your
analysis I mean I have to debate you
sometimes otherwise I just agree with
everything you say and it's just like
nodding I don't mind I
I know it's great to see you see you at
the diner all right good to see you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else